it has to be
[Music]
and so today
somebody said louder i love your energy
thank you
um so today we have janella from the new
york city central labor council to talk
to you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey family
it is my honor to be here with you
there's no other place i'd rather be and
as the secretary treasurer of the new
york city central labor council i
represent all of um labor along with my
partner vinnie alvarez all of labor in
new york city so first i want to shout
out our family in dc37 we have naisna we
have 1199 psc and uft
in the house along with many other
working people right
and i want you to know that working
people in organized labor are outraged
by what we have seen on the internet in
the last couple of days but it's time
it's time for us to stand up and make
sure that our voices are heard right and
our history as union members
reminds us that every right we've ever
gotten
we've gotten because of collective
action we've gotten because of struggle
right everything we've gotten
[Music]
the constitutional right to privacy
is intended to ensure that anybody who
wants an abortion can get one that is
the goal because abortion is healthcare
abortion is healthcare
abortion is healthcare
these people want to take away the
rights
of people who have the opportunity to be
pregnant and as was said so eloquently
earlier they may be targeting women but
we know it's not only women who can be
pregnant
[Applause]
we know that this attack on health care
is about
fighting against workers this is also
about voters rights this is also about
trans rights this is also about how
we're treating
lgbtq people this is about how we're
treating immigrants this is about how
we're treating young people this is
about attack on our public education
system
[Applause]
it's about the unhoused it's about the
poor it's about the voiceless
but we
we here today we are standing together
we're going to keep on walking we're
going to keep on talking and we're going
to keep on fighting we're going to keep
on agitating we're going to keep on
moving to ensure that we get the
legislation we need to make sure that
abortion is the health care that is
protected for every person in this
country
know that labor stands with you
labor stance we are standing together
and we're going to fight this fight
together thanks everybody
[Applause]
rights are under attack what do we do
when women's rights are under attack
what do we do
when repo justice is under attack what
do we do
what do we do
what do we do
thank you thank you
[Applause]
all right so the one thing i like doing
more than talking about abortion is
funding abortion
you'll get an abortion you'll get an
abortion
all right so i it's a pleasure for me to
bring up chelsea maddie and julia of the
new york abortion access fund
[Applause]
oh my gosh what a beautiful crowd there
is so much beauty in our collective
power and we're so glad to be with you
tonight my name is maddie
i'm chelsea
and i'm julia
we are part of the new york abortion
access fund
and
our mission is simple we fund abortions
we support anyone who is living in or
traveling to new york who needs an
abortion and can't afford it
[Music]
we have existed for over 20 years and we
are not going anywhere
[Applause]
we are a group of volunteers and every
day we hear from callers who are facing
barriers to getting an abortion
our role is to meet people where they
are and to show up with compassion and
with trust
[Music]
with our community we can move resources
boldly so that people can get the care
that they need and the care that they
deserve
we are part of a network across the
country of abortion funds who make
abortion access possible and we do this
work despite bans despite the supreme
court despite abortion stigma and
inaction and neglect from politicians
and i want to say too that here in new
york there are far too many people who
are falling through the cracks already
every day we support callers from a wide
variety of experiences we are supporting
trans non-binary callers
[Applause]
we support people who are impacted by
our unjust prison system
we support people who are facing our
city's affordable housing crisis
domestic violence survivors
working parents young people sex workers
and undocumented folks
[Applause]
[Music]
and we believe fundamentally that
justice emerges when we have what we
need to live with dignity all of us
[Applause]
all right y'all
so
i woke up this morning feeling probably
like a lot of you did
angry angry
but also heartbroken right and i'm
really grateful to be in the space with
all of you but i'm especially especially
sending love to folks who've had
abortions
folks who are about to have abortions
[Applause]
you hear me
so i've had more than one abortion i
have a question
and i say that for the first time
publicly with pride
knowing
right
[Music]
so here's what we know right we know
that we're gonna continue getting
abortions
right
we know that rho was never enough the
supreme court was never enough
folks who are low-income folks living in
the south folks in the midwest have been
living in a quote-unquote post-world
world for years
[Applause]
[Music]
and we also here's what we also know we
know that we're not surprised
we know that rj reproductive justice
leaders have been sounding the alarm for
years
we knew that this [ __ ] was coming
we knew it
we're here we're ready and we need to
continue to put our trust and listen to
reproductive justice organizations and
leaders who who got all the tools
already we do not need to reinvent the
wheel abortion funds are here we're not
going anywhere and we're going to
continue to support folks who need
abortions no matter what
[Applause]
so before i pass it choose it
i just want to remind everybody this is
heartbreaking but again the supreme
court will not save us can y'all say
that with me the supreme court will not
save us they didn't save us they're not
gonna save us but guess who is
we
we got us
we got us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
universal child care and a reality where
every pregnancy outcome including
abortion is accessible to everyone
without stigma or shame
but in the meantime we will keep showing
up for people every single day who call
us and we need your help you can help us
in three ways first by donating
we need your money um we gave out over
400 000 last year to directly support
callers seeking care and we will
continue to do so
we need volunteers we all are fully
volunteer run organization and we need
your help to answer calls to
talk with callers and to help fund
abortion
and finally we want you all to join us
in chanting who's got us
thank you everyone
[Applause]
go ahead
come on
okay
a little louder
come on
we got us
i love it
i love it
i love the energy you all have been here
out here for some hours and i really
appreciate you for being out here
because this work is long
and hard and we're going to hear from a
couple of more speakers today
oh thank you come on
we've been talking a lot today about the
fact that roe is going to fall right but
you know what really needs to fall white
supremacist imperialist capitalist
hatred
[Applause]
a lot of things in this country need to
fall and that's what our focus needs to
be on so the next person i'm going to
invite to the stage is sonya from now
nyc
[Applause]
hello everyone wow this is such an
amazing sight you've given me hope today
has been such a tough day to see all of
you here
but this is just the start
right it's just the start we've got to
keep this energy up and i know we've
been here before
but now it really really counts we've
got such amazing organizations that
you've heard from here that are right
here in new york city that can give you
a home whatever type of work and
activism you want to do
to push us in the right direction it is
here i'm with the national organization
for women of new york city the
birthplace
for now
and we welcome you to join us
in this fight because we've got to do a
few key things
we got to be loud and proud just like we
are here or today
every day we gotta do it and we'll be
there to take you help you take it to
them
we gotta make sure to elect the right
people
the right leaders who are gonna stand up
for our values and our lives
you've been with us when we've gotten on
the bus to go
in all different directions to make sure
that happens we've got to keep doing
that we've got to think about the long
game
you can participate anyway
you would like you've got skills bring
it to us please visit our website
nownyc.org
to find out how you can get involved
tomorrow night we're having a
zoom meeting that's just to start we're
back in person
just remember this is
the most significant setback for women's
rights in the history of this country
we've got to turn it around
we've got to go state by state
to make sure
that family and women and people who
need abortions
are able to get the care that they need
because bans
don't prevent unplanned pregnancies
[Applause]
bans don't give
families the money they need to be able
to raise a family
not at all
so thank you so very much
let me ask you this
what do we want
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you how are y'all feeling
all right i'm glad everybody's still
energized because we have more speakers
[Music]
all right i'm also gonna on that note
ask our speakers to please keep your
comments to one to two minutes
yes i got the yes all right so our next
speaker is dina
had hood from malika
[Music]
[Applause]
my body
my body
thank you my name is dina and i'm a
queen's resident i'm a repro organizer
and i'm the programs manager at an
organization called malika
malika is a new york city founded
movement led by women and non-binary
folks across the globe who teach
self-defense healing justice organizing
and financial literacy right so you
might be asking what does this have to
do with repro rights right
self-defense and everything we do is
about bodily autonomy it's key that we
defend our bodily autonomy not just from
physical attacks but from legal and
systemic ones as well
[Applause]
if we want to build a more just world a
world where we can thrive step into our
power build safety for our communities
we need to demand an end to these
constant attacks
on reproductive freedom and not only
stand against a potential scotus
decision but also think about the
current access and lack of access to
abortion we currently have right
[Music]
so i know i was asked to be quick i'd
like to share a quick quote by one of my
favorite writers andrea gibson who says
any feminist who has ever taken the high
road will tell you that the high road
gets backed up and sometimes we have to
take a detour directly to outrage to get
things done
so i want to thank you
all the organizers of this rally for
creating a way for us to channel that
rage and that energy that we all have
four years ago i was actually in the
same exact spot collecting signatures
right against um the confirmation of
justice kavanaugh to the supreme court
right so we've been out here
yeah and the chance at that time was
kavanaugh so when i say cabba you say no
cabba
right so we've been out here and i just
i just want to point that out right
because we're going to continue to do
this work up until this decision after
this decision and we're not going to
stop right
until we continue to fight for
reproductive justice and we continue to
fight for self-determination for our
community so thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we're gonna hear from our
next speaker sage from new york city for
abortion rights
[Music]
[Applause]
hello so i'll start by saying every
person has the right to abortion not
just women
every person
it will be remiss of me not to mention
the importance of uplifting black
indigenous and people of color right now
it will be remiss of me not to mention
the importance of also uplifting trans
non-binary and queer people as well as
undocumented people
it will also be remiss of me not to
mention that the police presence here
today is so harmful since the nypd on
more than one occasion has protected
pro-lifers or antis as we call them who
have harassed clinic workers and
patients
is no reproductive justice without
racial justice and there is no
reproductive justice without trans and
queer liberation
our struggles and our pain are
intersectional
everyone here right now my question for
you is what will it take people should
have been uplifting reproductive
organizations that have been doing this
work for decades people should have
already been radicalized clearly our
vote is not working since this [ __ ] in
the supreme court is already taking
place we will clear we clearly see that
politicians don't protect them from
politicians don't protect reproductive
rights and democrats won't save us you
know who is preparing for this
local reproductive organizations we must
take direct action organize and build
communities so we can get to revolution
if you cannot take direct action and
support your local abortion mutual aid
fund if you cannot take direct action
then amplify clinic defenders clinic
workers and the voices of patients this
isn't to be punitive or harsh we need to
build compute community capacity and we
need to stop being we we need to stop
being reactive and start being proactive
since 1973 when roe vs wade was voted in
47 countries have legalized or
decriminalized abortion last year alone
argentina south korea and thailand
legalized or decriminalized abortion
this year
colombia has decriminalized abortion how
did they get their rights
they fought they didn't stand around and
rally they fought and took their rights
they left their government no choice but
to give people legal health care and a
human right yet here we are in one of
the most developed nations in the world
and we're reversing time taking away
life-saving medical procedures no matter
what it takes we won't stop until we
have a right to abortion to stay
thank you
[Applause]
that was so beautiful
um
they say get organized right what are we
gonna do we're gonna get
organized yes
wherever you are located whatever your
field of work is doing do something for
reproductive justice today tomorrow and
the next day when i started this rally
what did i tell y'all we must become a
menace to our enemies
they can't know no peace
[Music]
and so it's a beautiful time to remind
the doctors the clinicians the health
care workers that they also need a
reproductive justice framework analysis
right just because you're a doctor don't
mean that you are inherently a doctor in
service of reproductive justice
[Music]
and so today we have somebody who is a
doctor and wants to stand for repo
justice dr anna rossler is going to
speak
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hi everyone
i am dr rossler a resident physician at
jacoby in the bronx
[Applause]
and a proud member of my union the
committee of interns and residents sbi
[Applause]
we represent more than 20 000 resident
physicians across the country and right
now we have all been shaken to our core
we are angry we are tired we are worried
for our patients and we are worried for
all our members and all health care
workers who provide abortion care
first i'd like to tell all ob gyn
physicians abortion providers and other
staff who support women's full access to
reproductive health care that we stand
with you
[Music]
[Applause]
every single service that we provide is
life affirming care and i commend you
for doing the difficult work you do in
an environment that often condemns us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a physician our responsibilities to
patients go far beyond doing no harm our
responsibility and the collective
responsibility of all health care
providers is ensuring that all patients
can access the information and care that
they need to ensure their well-being and
that of their families
this means ensuring safe affordable
quality health care for families
including access to abortion
[Applause]
as a pediatric physician it isn't
uncommon for me to encounter patients
who have experienced guilt who have felt
a sense of stigmatization or have
struggled after having an abortion
from a healthcare perspective this also
directly impacts women and families
mental and emotional health when we
limit the full spectrum of healthcare
services that directly impacts the
well-being of our communities and
unfairly cast the blame on women it
fosters inequity and limits the
protections that we have fought for for
decades
[Applause]
the fact of the matter is that the
actions of the supreme court affect much
more than just abortion rights
overturning roe v wade could potentially
criminalize people from many states
including my home state of indiana just
for seeking health care or providing it
the constant regulation of women's
bodies autonomy reproductive freedom and
access to health care is an issue that
all positions can directly impact i
choose to support a health care system
that allows us a full access to the
health care we need so that we can have
healthy families and communities we
[Music]
we will not be silent we will not rest
our patients deserve better our
communities deserve better our country
deserves better abortion access is
health care access
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and to say that i am saddened could not
be more of an understatement we are
enraged and we will fight for what is
right together thank you
[Applause]
when repo rights are under attack what
do we do
oh
[Music]
what do we do
what do we do
what do we do
if we don't get it turn it down if we
don't get it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our worship providers our health care
providers our abortion escorts right
folks every day providing care for folks
who have abortions
[Applause]
and as bria said to our clinicians
people self-manage abortions who do not
call the police that is not your job
hello
your job is to support folks in having
and getting abortions thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we're going to hear from diva
ruiz and
thank god for abortion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right
i don't know if you can hear these air
horns
[Music]
we are back up for abortion
[Music]
that's right we're the party people i've
had multiple abortions god loves me do i
look ashamed
[Music]
nope
we represent all kinds all kinds of
people we are queer
we are non-binary we are trans we are
bipod centered we are poor centered
okay
what am i gonna i'm gonna ask god to
tell me what to say maybe i should have
written something but you know what i
believe in god that's the truth
i believe in god i have an incredible
life today because of the two abortions
i've had
that's my story
what do you think about that tgfa you
know what poor choice is is all right
but have you tried pro-abortion
when i say pro you say abortion blue
but i
we don't have any kind
of shame about this today we don't have
to be polite we can just say it we're
gonna say
[Music]
up here so what's important let me see
you know what it's an opportunity it's a
shitty day
i felt terrible today
right you did too
but look i have pom poms in my hand
because it's a good day it's an
opportunity it's a it's an opening
to welcome people into the movement it's
your time
it's your
time
okay
we've been at this so many of us have
been at this come join us we welcome you
it is your time being loud
follow the leadership
of abortion clinics providers and the
people who have abortions
how does that feel
[Music]
abortion bans is class war
that's what it is
right
okay so
i'm gonna leave you with a blessing here
you know what trans rights
are inextricable from abortion rights
right
so let me introduce my friend scouts of
christine's gonna say a word about that
i am scout i used to say them pronouns
i'm a transgender and intersex policy
advocate
[Applause]
so speakers today have already made
really great points about trans and
disabled people having abortions too
i wanted to take a moment to also point
out how disabled and intersex people are
also often sterilized without consent
typically at young ages
there are no laws in the united states
currently granting reproductive autonomy
to these populations
when we talk about the fight for
reproductive justice we must understand
that disabled and intersex lives are
also disproportionately impacted
that's right baby okay that's what we
have come to tell you we tell you that
we love you i wish you every blessing
god loves you god loves us god loves
abortion thank god for abortion let's go
thank god for abortion dead god form
abortion dead god four abortion day god
for abortion thank god thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so amazing i want to just thank
you all for that
um there's so
much on my heart as i keep introducing
these speakers but i think i'm thinking
about the fact that the united states
supreme court has no moral authority
none
whatsoever
[Music]
and a country with some of the worst
birth outcomes cannot tell you what to
do with your body
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all are so funny over here i love it
um
and so next up we have donna lieberman
for the new york civil liberties union
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here to stand with women
transgender
and non-binary people
[Music]
from texas
mississippi
all over the country
for abortion justice for reproduction of
justice for equality
[Applause]
you know for decades we've looked to the
course to vindicate our rights
but if this leaked opinion becomes final
this supreme court will be responsible
for the most significant assault on
women in history
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's remember
this court has already demonstrated
their disdain for racial equality by
gunning the voting rights act
[Applause]
[Music]
and we know all too well
that they have in their crosshairs
remember they like guns
they have in their crosshairs the rights
of
lgbtq people especially
trans youth
[Applause]
[Music]
they have in their crosshairs marriage
equality
access to contraception and just about
every principle of equality
americans support
but we're not just gonna stand here and
watch
we're gonna turn our outrage into action
[Applause]
we're going to protect women in new york
and welcome women and girls
and trans people
from all over the country so that they
can get the health care here in new york
that they need then they can't get it
home
you know
we fought for over a decade to pass the
reproductive health act in new york
and we won
[Applause]
we won
because new yorkers know
that abortion is healthcare
[Applause]
[Music]
new yorkers know that healthcare is a
right and we believe in freedom and
justice
[Applause]
and because of the ring right of health
act
in new york
roe v wade is state law no matter what
the supreme court says
[Applause]
that's right
in new york abortion is a fundamental
right
period
[Applause]
but now that's not even enough
we need to do more
we need to pass the equality amendment
the equality amendment to the new york
constitution will enshrine that right in
our state constitution so it can't be
taken away or criminalized
[Applause]
we also need to put our money
where our values are and fund abortion
without questions without conditions
[Applause]
[Music]
isn't the first time new york is being
called on to open our doors as we did it
before row and we will do it again
[Applause]
remember till that stupid opinion
becomes formal abortion is still legal
everywhere in the country
and will fight until they release
whatever opinion they release and will
keep fighting afterwards
[Music]
guys this is the fight of our lives
today
thousands of us across the country are
in the streets
but tomorrow we'll fund the phone lines
we'll take to the streets again
and most important
we will turn out to vote in the
by-elections
as if our lives depended on it
guess what our lives depended on it
and we won't rest until women's
fundamental right is restored not just
to new york but nationwide
my body
[Music]
support clinic escorts in new york city
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
yes
okay
all right y'all so um it's deeply
important in this movement that we hear
the stories of folks who have had an
abortion
abortion storytellers move this movement
so i'm going to introduce an abortion
storyteller athena
who's going to share her story with us
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all are loud
hi
i'm too tall
my name is athena
i had an abortion when i was 17.
i found out i was pregnant my first week
of college
shortly after yes
shortly after moving into my dorm
i'm not sure i can fully describe the
feeling
thinking you're on the cusp of adulthood
just starting to put your foot in the
folks are
just starting to put your foot in the
water
i'll need to immediately fall into the
deep end
right away even through the initial
shock i knew abortion was the right
choice for me
[Applause]
i felt peace and relief that what i
thought was the hard part the making of
an impossible decision was over
but i had no idea how difficult it would
be to actually enact my choice
at that time in massachusetts where i
was in school you couldn't get an
abortion at 17 without parental consent
so without a car
without a job without a support system
in massachusetts it took me and my
boyfriend almost a month to be able to
purchase bus tickets to take a peter
banned bus to connecticut to get an
abortion pill
it was only three and a half weeks but
it felt like eternity the world was
moving so fast around me my roommate was
making friends and joining clubs and i
was trying to hold myself together for
just a pair of bus tickets
and despite all of the planning
and all of the work and missed classes
to finally make it to a planned
parenthood thank you planned parenthood
[Applause]
we found out at my appointment that i
was a few days too far along and that we
would have to figure out how to come
back across state lines for a dnc at a
later time
when i first heard what was happening in
texas i broke down
because i understand
from experience exactly how helpless it
feels to be forced to walk through fire
to execute a lawful right to choose
[Music]
[Applause]
and now
with the leaked scotus opinion
i knew i could no longer stay silent
because my experience is the experience
of far too many people in this country
and all of our voices have a right to be
heard
[Music]
[Applause]
no one no one should have to fight for
autonomy over their own body
no one should have to cross state lines
to get an abortion
[Applause]
reproductive agency is a human right
and we have to stand up to protect
access to abortion care for everybody
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
please give it up one more time it takes
so much courage to tell your story
thank you
all right
so
the next speaker we have today is joy
callaway from planned parenthood of
greater new york
[Music]
wake
up
wake up
[Music]
wake
up
everybody
no more sleeping in bed
no more backward thinking time for
thinking ahead
[Applause]
wake up
all you teachers
time to teach a new way
maybe then they'll listen to what we
have to say
wake
up
all you builders
time to build a new land
[Applause]
i know we can do it but we all
must lend a hand the world and go get no
better
if we just
let it be
i said the world ain't gonna get no
better
we have to change it yes
you
and me
[Applause]
i'm not gonna say good evening i'm just
gonna say hey
i am joy d calloway i'm the interim
chief executive officer of planned
parenthood greater new york action fund
[Music]
i usually go to work and say i woke up
like this but today i woke up in shock
it's like i was in a time warp those
lyrics were 47 years ago and i'm
repeating them today and they apply
today
we are at a crisis moment people
i said we are in a crisis in this moment
this devastating and politically
motivated supreme court opinion
is a roadmap
a cookbook
a how to
dismantle our fundamental rights to a
safe and legal abortion
this is a fundamental right that was
codified federally 49 years ago
and with a leak and a slip of the pin
it's about to be gone
we are in a crisis
this court is completely prepared to end
the constitutional right to an abortion
let that sink in
this is not hyperbole
this is not hypothetical
this is not could happen could not
this is happening and it's happening now
before our very eyes
right now
our deepest fears are being realized
right now
how did you feel when you woke up this
morning
this outcome
is as dangerous as it is
unprecedented and this will open the
floodgates for all of those states that
just been itching to take this away
itching to change this
and make no mistake
this is just the beginning they got a
whole list of things they want to do the
next thing is a nationwide ban
you all saw the guapo article yesterday
anti-abortion groups and their cronies
in congress have been meeting in secret
behind the scenes to plan a national
attack on abortion rights
[Music]
[Applause]
and my notes say when the supreme court
rolls it back come on y'all it says if
but we know it's finn the supreme court
rules back abortion rights
we know our narrow-minded politician
friends
are going to try to take power
in washington and we know they're going
to start pulling this apart across the
entire country is that what we want
[Applause]
i say again
wake up
26 states
are ready to immediately
ban abortion the second row is
overturned not the next week not the
next month not the next day the second
this decision comes out and row is
overturned 26 states like dominoes are
going to fall
are we happy with this
let me be clear
abortion bans
are designed
to deny black latinx asian indigenous
people
our right to control our bodies and our
futures these vans disproportionately
harm people who are in lower incomes and
cannot afford access to health care
already
so this is just going to make it work
wake up
abortion bans are a perpetuation of
racism sexism misogyny economic
injustice it's just a sign and it's the
top of a slippery slope y'all but let me
be clear today what says may 3rd 2022
abortion is legal
today abortion is legal
it remains our constitutional right and
thanks to rep
reproductive rights champions across
this great state of new york it is
codified in our state constitution here
in the state of new york
[Applause]
and while you celebrate and i hear my
drummers this is not a time to rest
this is a time to wake up and to
mobilize and to make sure that we let
people know that anything less than
complete access to an abortion to
whomever wants it whenever we want it is
the only thing that we're going for
complete access to whomever wants it
whatever they wanted
[Music]
we here in new york and i said that
proudly this isn't my home state but my
home state is one of those domino states
so they don't get a call out tonight
here in new york
we must do everything we can everything
in our power to protect and expand
access here for everyone who needs us
and those that are going to
unfortunately have to travel across
state lines like the young sister that
just spoke so that they can get
essential and basic health care because
abortion is health care
[Music]
and health care happens at planned
parenthood of greater new york
[Applause]
we are incredibly proud to be part of a
strong coalition of essential abortion
health care providers and we will
continue to fight to keep abortion safe
legal and accessible we are proud to
provide abortion to everyone who needs
it new yorkers or not
and today is the day we must wake up we
must do something different we must let
our voices be heard we must make sure
abortion is safe and legal across these
great united states of america
after you wake up
i need you to lead and lead loudly thank
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
abortion is health care
i mean we're out here to make it
abundantly clear
abortion is health care
so we're getting to the end of our
program i want to take this opportunity
to thank every single person that showed
up here today
[Music]
[Applause]
like we said when we began you could
have been anywhere in this world but you
decided to join us out here
and i do not take that for granted
[Music]
i'd also like to thank the person one of
the best organizers i know that is the
reason why we're here sasha ahuja
[Applause]
[Music]
it is not easy to get folks to show up
and show up and so i want to thank sasha
and all the organizers that got together
and answered the call and said yes we
will do this
because it is important to us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a few notes before we peace out
one a reminder
abortion is still legal in this country
[Music]
if you have an appointment for an
abortion tomorrow go
two
environmental justice is reproductive
justice so
if you brought a sign a water bottle
some paper a flag take it with you
[Applause]
[Music]
this city does not sleep and it also
does not clean itself
let's get in right relationship with
this planet right now
and last but not least this does not end
we are coming back together for a mass
mobilization on may 14th so whoever told
you to show up here please contact that
person and find out where we're spotting
up on may 14th
[Applause]
union square two o'clock
union square two o'clock
[Music]
all right y'all so
um y'all understood one two and three
[Applause]
all right cause i'm gonna be looking
especially for number two like
i don't wanna see nothing nothing take
it with you even if it's not yours my
grandma said leave a place cleaner than
you found it
give it up for our mc's bring out
they did this for two hours
two and a half hours
god bless them
thank you
why am i here y'all already know what
i'm about to make y'all do
exactly
so whenever something is on my heart i
love to chat because that's what keeps
our spirits going right so today if you
don't know this i'm gonna teach you the
asada chat
it's cute what y'all doing back there
but that's how we doing right now what
we're gonna do right now is be inside a
chat and this is a call and response so
repeat after me when i say these things
okay it is our duty to fight for our
freedom
it is
[Music]
i can't hear you it is our duty to fight
for our freedom
[Music]
it is our duty to
[Music]
we must love and protect one another
[Music]
we have nothing to lose
[Applause]
but our chains
it is our duty to fight for our freedom
we must win
[Applause]
reproductive justice today
tonight
tomorrow
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]